hey you guys welcome once again to my
flickers of fear movie review show now
just like last month uh when we did folk
horror february
i thought that for march we would also
do a little bit of a theme i'm not gonna
you know i don't want to be too rigid
about it but i thought since it was
march we would do monster movies
so i thought it was a good time to visit
this film because this is one that
actually has been on my to watch list
for a really long time and actually
i think if i remember correctly i
thought i started watching it a couple
years back and then for whatever reason
just never i think maybe i only got like
five or ten minutes into it for never
whatever reason just like never finished
it probably because i had to go do
something else or whatever and just like
forgot about it
but since then
uh because i've become more familiar
with the writer director team who did
this movie
uh and i had seen some of their other
movies and really liked them a lot i was
kind of like yeah i should really get
around to like watching this and also
very recently um i've had a couple
recommendations from some of you guys as
well
that this is a movie that you wanted to
see me talk about so this is the movie
spring from 2014.
now
i think this is one of those movies that
it's best going into it knowing as
little as possible so if you haven't
seen it and you would and you do want to
watch it then i would advise like not
watching this i'm not going to spoil the
ending
but i will kind of spoil you know a few
things that happened in it they're
probably better
left like not known when you're first
watching the movie
however one thing i will say uh just to
kind of winnow out people that
you know maybe wouldn't enjoy this movie
is that please
don't go into this thinking that it's
a traditional straight-up monster movie
there is a monster in it
uh it is a monster movie but
it is mostly
a romance
now
i know how i know what you're thinking
like i know some people would be like
why the [ __ ] would i want to watch that
but
honestly
this is one of the most audacious i
think like genre crossers that's been
done a long time and you know it's been
done before like the horror romance
hybrid not a lot
but honestly this
is really kind of the best example of
that that i can think of and believe me
i'm really not into
romance movies i don't like chick flicks
i don't generally like
love so i'm not like averse to them but
it's not really a genre i seek out very
much
so again it was it's very kind of ballsy
to make what is essentially
a love story but with a monster
component
i've seen this compared a lot to uh the
richard linklater like before trilogy
like before sunrise before sunset those
movies uh and it does have i'm i think
uh on purpose i think it does like
homage those movies it's so it's like a
horror like a body horror or a slightly
lovecraftian version of that uh if that
sounds like something you want to watch
because like i said it is a horror movie
there is a monster but
it's mainly
watching these two characters
falling in love with one another and
learning to accept uh each other's
quirks which in this case are uh quite
severe so so there's that and honestly i
don't think that's too much of a spoiler
because if you see the most iconic
poster for this you can kind of see
you can kind of get a hint of what's
going on and i think even the tagline
for the movie says love is a monster so
you know it's not that crazy and i think
if you've read it came out in 2014 so
it's been a few years and i think a lot
of people have talked about it
in terms of it being a monster movie but
just don't approach it thinking that
it's going to be like a traditional
monster movie so this was written and
directed by the team of justin benson
and aaron morehead who worked together
pretty much all the time
uh they also did resolution uh which i
think was their first kind of feature
length film this might have been their
second one probably best known nowadays
for the endless which i have seen but i
don't think i've reviewed it yet even
though i love that movie it's brilliant
that's also kind of like a lovecraftian
uh movie as well uh cosmic horror type
thing and i probably will get around to
reviewing that at some point because i
love that movie and they've also done a
couple more recent ones that
that i've either reviewed or that tom
and i reviewed because i think we
reviewed
after midnight
uh i think tom and i both reviewed that
and uh she dies tomorrow i think i just
reviewed that by myself if i'm
remembering correctly so i have seen a
lot of their uh output
so if you liked now if you liked the
endless you would probably really dig
this if you haven't seen it because this
is the one that came out a movie or two
before that one
so uh i think they've also done a couple
they also did a couple episodes of
archive 81 and some other things along
that line so you know they've they've
been quite busy and like i said this is
a movie that gets talked about maybe not
as much as the endless because i feel
like that's kind of the one that
everybody talks about
uh but this is kind of like the second
one you know behind that that everybody
talks about so the story behind this
is that at the very beginning we're
following this young man named evan
russell
now at the beginning you know that this
dude is like a good guy because
he has uh been spending apparently the
last several months of his life maybe
longer uh caring for his mother who is
dying of cancer um you also find out
that his father died quite suddenly not
too long ago like of a heart attack and
since then he's kind of been
taking care of his mom and just like
working as a cook in a restaurant to
kind of like support them even though
it's not really like what his big dream
is
so very close to the beginning of the
film his mother passes away
and uh shortly after this because he's
kind of left at sixes and sevens um he
gets into he's you know at the
restaurant where he works like drinking
with his friend tommy
and you know he gets kind of drunk he
gets into a fight not really his fault
but he's sort of like provoked into it a
little bit and he ends up beating the
[ __ ] out of the guy because you know
they've just come from his mom's funeral
and it's really like he's not in a good
place
so the guy who owns the restaurant is
like look i really don't want to have to
like fire you but you know the cops are
coming around that guy might press
charges and it's like you know maybe we
can bring you back later on
you know but we just can't have you
around here right now so he's lost his
parents he's lost his job and he really
doesn't know what he wants to do with
his life
and he got a little bit of money uh like
inheritance from his parents death so
his friend says why don't you just get
the [ __ ] out of here for a while it's
like you know the cops are going to be
sniffing around you might get in trouble
if that guy presses charges for the
fight it's like want to just take off
you know somewhere and just get out of
here and kind of find yourself
so he doesn't really know where to go
he just has money and a passport and
he's like oh well me and my dad always
talked about maybe going to italy one
day uh we never got to go so he's like
what why not i'll just go there
so he just randomly goes there now
interestingly when he gets there at
first it's almost kind of like and i
think and i've seen a couple people that
like reviewed the movie that were kind
of like well you know why didn't he just
like why didn't they just start the
movie in italy or why did we have to
have this whole prologue
at the beginning but honestly i liked
that because as soon as he gets to italy
it almost seems like he's gonna repeat
the same [ __ ] like you can't run away
from yourself you know what i mean you
just find yourself when you get there
type of thing because as soon as he gets
there he falls in with these two kind of
really obnoxious but also kind of
lovable like british dudes and uh you
know they're very borish
and uh so you know and they kind of like
mirror his kind of schlubby pothead
friend
like tommy from back home where they're
just kind of like wandering around and
they don't really have any purpose in
life so he hangs out with them for a
while and they end up going to this kind
of like little seaside town um you know
he like i said he's kind of like
repeating the same stuff that was going
on back then but then like back when he
was at home
in california but then he meets this
mysterious young woman named louise
now louise um at first approaches him so
sort of forthrightly
that he kind of thinks she's like a
prostitute and that she's gonna just
like you know roll him or something just
because she's very forthright about uh
you know hey don't you want to like come
back to my place right now it's like the
middle of the afternoon and he's like at
a cafe with like the two british guys
and he's like well no come on let's you
don't you want to go on a date or
something like that she said yeah i
don't do that so she's kind of one of
these uh she likes sex but doesn't want
to become emotionally involved kind of
uh kind of girl
and he is uh you know he's like no i'll
pass on that but it's like i just i want
you to go out with me i want us to have
like a regular date she's reluctant but
i mean he really does seem to take a
shine to her and she seems to kind of
take a shine to him as well
so as the movie goes on um he's kind of
like because she's initially again
reluctant to get involved but he likes
her so much she's into so intrigued by
her that he does he doesn't like stalker
or anything it's not you know it's i
know how it sounds because i know they
do that a lot and like romantic comedies
which is one of the reasons that i don't
like them um where the dudes just like
keep pursuing the woman like even after
she's clearly said hey piss off i don't
want to date you but the way it's done
here is not like that at all it's not
creepy in the least because she actually
does seem interested in him and is
receptive to him she just you know she
just has walls up and uh as it turns out
she has a very good reason for that as
you discover as the movie goes on
so for a long time throughout the movie
it's basically following them around
this gorgeous
gorgeous um italian seaside village
uh you know and them just kind of like
going through the process of essentially
like falling in love with one another
now uh at this like evan's two british
friends who he'd been staying at a
hostel with they decide you know they're
kind of sick of italy and they piss off
to amsterdam but they think it's too
expensive so they piss off to amsterdam
uh they ask if evan wants to go but by
this time he's kind of become smitten
with louise so he's like no i think i'm
going to stay here but then he's kind of
running out of money so he finds this
situation where there's this old guy
named angelo
and he's uh willing to
trade him like kind of a crappy looking
like room for some work on his olive
farm so basically he does that just so
he can stay in town and kind of woo
louise
now as i said you know pretty much that
there has to be something the matter
with louise um and for a long time they
don't tell you exactly what it is it's
interesting because i was i saw like uh
one review of this i think it was like a
youtube review
and one of the uh comments said i kind
of wish
that
they hadn't like told you or or that it
wasn't um telegraphed that louise was a
monster because for a long time
um you weren't really sure if there was
going to be some kind of like torture
porn situation because you knew that
there was something
weird about her when she approached him
so forthrightly
uh the way she did so you know what i
mean so it was almost kind of like uh
what's that what was that movie with uh
natasha henster's species where she was
just trying to like reproduce herself
it's you know what you know what i mean
but
i did see some people that didn't that
weren't aware that it was a monster
movie
and said oh i kind of thought it was
going to go like in a hostile like
torture porn kind of direction which it
doesn't like i said it's absolutely a
monster maybe
so but for a long time they don't tell
you
what exactly her deal is you know what i
mean
and i will say i don't want to spoil
what kind of monster she is exactly
because i'm actually i don't even know
if i could spoil it because i'm not
entirely sure
i kind of like
that
the way that what she is is explained
sort of leaves a lot of things open it's
it's not supernatural really she's not
like a vampire or nothing like that
but
it leaves it it's
it's organic enough that
you could almost kind of buy it like in
a scientific sort of
man i mean not really because it's a
monster movie and if you see some of the
transformations that she goes through
you're like yeah okay that could have
happened in real life but
it's not as
supernatural like i said is like a
vampire or a werewolf or something like
that but for a long time you don't
really know because he and and evan
doesn't know either because he's like
falling in love with her they're kind of
going on dates she finally relents they
start like talking to each other and
she's you know very guarded
but uh they eventually start opening up
to one another and but at inopportune
times something will happen
like like the side of her face will
start like cracking and [ __ ] like that
and she's like oh [ __ ] and then she
takes out like these um
syringes and then she has to give
herself injections to make herself look
like a human again uh she also does [ __ ]
like
uh eats a cat so they don't show it but
they do kind of show you know they hint
that that's what she's going to do and
then they kind of show a little bit of
the
aftermath and she eats a rabbit so she
does like start eating
animals but
you know as upsetting as that is because
you know guys know how i feel about like
you seeing like [ __ ] up stuff
happening to animals and boobies but
at the same time she's such a likable
character that you feel sorry for her
because even though for a long time you
don't know what kind of monster she is
she doesn't seem to be able to help it
and uh she seems kind of like desperate
to oh [ __ ] you know i have to
get this back into like con under
control because you can tell that
at some stages like she can't control
what it is that she does because there's
just one scene where
she's uh on a date with evan and she
kind of starts to monster out and i
guess she doesn't have her syringe so
she's just like oh gotta go by you know
what i mean like she kind of runs off
and then she ends up in this alley uh
before you know she doesn't have time to
get home and like this you know jackass
like american tourist comes up to her
thinking she's a hooker and you know
tries to essentially rape her
and she just like turns around and like
[ __ ] eats i think she bites his dick
off actually but uh but yeah so there
was that so she can't really control
like what it is that she does
but i will say that a lot of the um
effects work that they did in this were
practical there is some cgi
but
the effects work in this like when like
her various monster forms look really
cool and like i said the mythology
behind the monster that she is
is really unique i don't they don't even
she doesn't even like have a name for it
there's not even a name for it but it
does have
lovecraftian uh and also like ancient
greek roman mythology type vibe to it
which i thought was kind of cool because
you don't really see a lot of movies
like because i don't know i kind of feel
like when they're gonna do a monster
movie they usually have like a defined
monster whereas this one was kind of
more like
not she's not a shape-shifter it's not
that it's just there but like i said
there's kind of like an embryonic
or an evolutionary genetic sort of
component to it which i thought was kind
of cool but yeah but you'll know if
you've seen like some of the um
some of the effects work they do on this
it's very like it's almost like
cronenbergian or even like like john
carpenter a little bit you know what i
mean like kind of the body horror type
stuff they have going on but it's really
really well done but everything about
this movie i mean honestly it seems like
most of the reviews i saw this because i
read a lot of different reviews of it
like uh over the last few days after
since i've seen it and almost all of
them overwhelmingly positive and this a
lot of it too from you know straight up
horror channels and a lot of the you
know horror channels like being run by
dudes and normally dudes in general
would not uh you know heterosexual dudes
in general would not watch
a romance film hell i would not watch a
romance film not usually it's not
usually a genre that i pick i'm not
completely averse to them but it's not
usually
something that i would choose to watch
you know what i mean by and large i find
them kind of annoying
but
uh so if you said oh it's like a romance
but she's a monster but the thing about
it is that the romance has to work and
in this one it absolutely works the
thing that's great about
uh about this movie
is that the acting performances uh lou
taylor pucci who was in uh thumb sucker
among other things and nadia hilker uh
she was in i've well she's been a lot of
stuff but i recognize her from the
walking dead actually like the last few
seasons
but
the two of them
they have really good chemistry with one
another and the way that their
relationship unfolds is so organic and
so naturalistic they seem so natural
with each other and the conversations
that they have sound like actual
conversations so it doesn't seem like
a cheesy sappy
rom-com or like a cheesy sappy
chick-flick type thing where it's just
these kind of like grand declarations of
blah blah blah it sounds like two young
people who are falling in love like
conversations they would actually have
with one another and they both seem like
very interesting characters so even
though it takes a while
for the whole monster thing to really
come to into full flower as it were i
was just riveted by these two characters
you know what i mean even though i
suspected that she was a monster
obviously
but i i liked them so much as characters
that i was like i kind of wanna i wanna
see where this is going like what's
gonna happen you know what i mean is she
gonna monster out and pull his head off
is she gonna you know you don't know
what's gonna happen and so and i think
that was really kind of like a testament
to the acting in this that even without
the monster element just watching the
two of them interacting with one another
and you know developing this
relationship
was interesting enough for me to be
really invested in their characters and
then just like when all the
you know gross technically monster stuff
came into it i was just kind of like
okay that's even better that's like you
know that's like that's like a whole
another like dimension to the thing and
i you know easily the thing about it is
that i mean the theme of this movie
obviously being
you know true love being
uh accepting somebody for who they are
even if they are a monster which sounds
crazy but it totally totally works in
this in a way that's really hard to
describe if you haven't seen it but uh
but yeah i mean i really really liked
this movie a lot it's probably one that
i will uh watch again i'm sure um i just
i don't know there was something about
it that i really loved like the
cinematography like i said beautiful um
you know this gorgeous sweeping shots of
like the italian seaside and
just beautiful beautiful shots and it
was just the character work was just so
good in it that like i said even without
the monster stuff i was still like
really invested in their relationship
even though like i said romance isn't
really a genre that i watch all that
much that i'm not really that big a fan
of but i mean this was absolutely
uh one of the best possible and to be
honest i can't really think
offhand
of another
um kind of horror romance that worked
quite as well as this i mean i guess you
could say something like okay well like
an american werewolf in london that was
kind of like i mean that was mostly a
horror movie but that had a romance kind
of thing in it too
and i think this was kind of more along
those lines like i said
mostly and pretty much every review says
this mostly this is
essentially like a richard linklater you
know before sunrise before sunset that
his before trilogy this is like that
like two characters falling in love in
like a beautiful uh location it's like
that but one of them is a monster you
know what i mean so it's like a horror
version of that uh but still mostly a
romance uh so if that kind of sounds
like
something you would like and like i said
if you're a if you're a horror guy and
you're like well i don't really like
romance i mean give it a shot anyway
because i don't like romance either and
i really really dug this because just i
really liked the way the genres were
blended i thought they did a really good
job and like i said i think it's not
just because of the monster [ __ ] which
was great but
also because just the two characters
were so likable and you got so invested
in their relationship uh that you wanted
to see what was going to happen to them
especially once the monster stuff got
revealed so if you've seen spring from
2014 or uh any of justin benson and
aaron morehead's other movies uh then
let me know in the comments i definitely
will be reviewing the endless at some
point because i know we've done a couple
of their other movies but we haven't
done the endless for whatever reason i
don't know why uh because i really did
like that movie so i'll get around to
doing that one as well but yeah um if
you've seen this let me know what you
think about in the comments i think it's
pretty it's streaming in a bunch of
different places um it's on tubey it's
on i think it used to be on shutter but
i don't think it's on there anymore oh
no mate yeah yeah it is on shutter so
it's on shutter it's on uh 2b for free i
think it's on amazon prime and uh so
it's a bunch of places very very easy to
see so uh if you haven't seen it then
watch it and let me know what you
thought if you have seen it then let me
know we thought about it in the comments
and that will do it for this flickers of
fear the first in our monster march uh
little theme that we're doing uh so i
will see you guys again on the next one
bye